the souls born games are memorable for
many reasons but none more so than the
bosses these guys represent some of the
most brutal and rewarding challenges in
gaming with a hundred and thirty nine of
them throughout five games that's a lot
of dying and now we're going to pick the
top 15 rankings will be based on a
combination of lower design and
challenge of course personal experience
plays a big role so there will be some
subjectivity to this oh and of course
spoilers for pretty much everything
perhaps the most unique boss in the
series old monk is a PvP fight with
another actual player
this means your feelings on the old monk
are going to depend entirely on your
personal experience was it an epic
inaudible duel or total [ __ ] where
they spam you with the scraping spear
these days you'll be hard-pressed to
actually find someone online meaning
you'll end up fighting the NPC version
which is a complete joke this makes us
the only boss that new players may never
get to experience still the potential
for an awesome PvP battle makes this a
one-of-a-kind for the series
without a doubt the best boss in vanilla
Dark Souls to the looking-glass night
brings spectacle and challenge however
what really brings us fight up a level
is that halfway through he will summon
an NPC invader to assist what makes this
so special is that if a player places
their sign outside of the arena they
will be summoned instead bringing the
challenge of this fight up significantly
his lore is a little whatever just being
another test for those wishing to seek
the King but the environment in which
you fight him in is pretty awesome
dragon fights have always been a
hallmark for the series and for our
money the best one belongs to the final
boss of the crown of the second King DLC
send the slumbering dragon sin was a
slumbering dragon that was worshiped
before a knight attempted to kill him
this awoke the dragon who proceeded to
kill everyone in the kingdom with his
poisonous breath tragic stuff the fight
itself is a tough one sin hits hard it
only gives a limited window to attack
which means you need to be on your
a-game for this fight getting hit by his
poison doesn't help either it's an
exhilarating fight and incredibly
satisfying when you take him down
the twin princes is a great example of
the story working together with the
mechanics of the fight Prince lothric
destined to be a lord of cinder was born
cursed weak and frail his elder brother
Lorin chooses to embrace his curse with
him out of love losing the use of his
legs and voice the first phase with
Lawren requires awareness as his
teleportation can easily defeat those
not ready
the second brings lothric into the mix
building on the fight with magic
projectiles is a duel fight without
actually being one and the resurrection
mechanic for Lorin adds challenge while
not being obnoxious like it was with the
throne Watchers and defender from to it
smartly uses elements from other fights
and puts them together in a fantastic
way
in a sea of fights that are memorable
for their spectacle sir alonne stands
out for his simplicity a one-on-one duel
between two warriors he's a brutal
fighter and ranks as one of the series
toughest challenges conquering this
optional boss is a rewarding experience
and there was even a bonus for those
masters that can do it without being hit
where sir alonne will commit seppuku out
of shame the lore is wonderfully tragic
as well
sir along was a knight from a foreign
land who befriended aligned himself with
the old iron king but as the king became
more cruel and twisted elan abandoned
him he still keeps the Kings humble
throne with him as a reminder of days
long past
blinded by his obsession with Natalia
the night rain left his post and became
the demonic fume Knight determined to
protect her and protect her he shall
because few night is one of the absolute
hardest fights in the series his attacks
deal massive damage it will put your
dodge timing to the test his second
phase is even worse changing his attack
speed adding projectiles and even an AoE
attack and if you manage to get him low
you better have destroy the astronauts
outside the arena first otherwise few
Knight will heal himself thankfully the
bonfire is close by for an easy Trek
otherwise this fight might be too
frustrating even if you hate the few
Knight most players can't deny the
satisfaction of besting it this fight is
one that gets on here pretty much just
for the lore Demon Souls is all about
being the noble hero killing evil demons
but here that narrative is challenged
for maiden Austria a character said by
many to have forsaken everyone and her
faith to use the power of the demons
actually did so out of selflessness for
the faith she served did nothing to help
the poor and the suffering in the valley
of defilement
but the demonic power she gained did
posing the question of who is the real
demon it's the only moment in the series
that makes you the player question if
what you're doing is the right thing
you're not likely to fight Estrella
herself but rather her loyal knight garl
Vinland defeating gaul results in
Estrella committing suicide but if you
manage to kill her first girl will fall
into despair and be dead next time you
visit either way it's a tragic end to
one of the series most interesting
bosses do as you like
take your promises do
perhaps the hardest fight in the whole
series of the nameless king is a beast
of a boss first off this boss gets
massive lower points for finally
answering the question of who is going
Spurs son spoilers it's this guy and you
get a fight him in this suitably epic
arena in an intense two phase fight the
king of storms face has him riding on
his dragon while the second phase is a
wild one showdown that pushes the player
to their limits this is in a lot of ways
a battle of attrition as the nameless
King has such a large health pool that
players need to stay on top of their
game the whole time the only thing
keeping him from being higher on this
list is that the camera in the fight is
pretty janky particularly during the
king of storms things IDO Weiss comes
down to the hunters helper to clean up
after these sorts of misses
what makes Cameron such a great final
boss depending on the ending you get is
that he's a true test of skill and your
mastery of blood Barnes mechanics
there's such a great build-up to this
fight with gehrman being the crippled
old man starts you on the journey and
now you must face him the presentation
is great as well
the flower-filled the burning workshop
the music it all works together to give
a real sense of finality to it now if
there's one complaint if you're really
good in a little overpowered gehrman
might not be that tough but for most
he's a fair and fun challenge
what borns only DLC the old hunters
wants to beat you down with its
difficulty and proved it wasn't messing
around with its first boss ludwig via
Kherson while the leader of the church
hunters is certainly memorable for is
horrifying grotesque or face aggressive
attacks one hit kills and whatever the
heck this thing is what truly cements
him is halfway through when this happens
now donning the title of the holy blade
you engage in what is basically a
completely different boss battle
featuring from software's iconic
moonlight greatsword if you thought the
first face was tough he now has massive
AOE s and huge projectiles that are
capable of killing you in one hit it's a
brutal fight but the moment you stick
him with that visceral attack to finish
them off one of the most satisfying
things you'll do also the soundtrack is
super animated
artorias of the abyss is the dlc that
set up the soul series is having some of
the best in gaming so it's appropriate
that knight artorias himself would make
for one of the series best bosses
Artorius is a legendary Knight known for
being able to take on the abyss but now
consumed by it you must defeat him
our Tory ace is non-stop aggressive with
high damage dealing attacks the few
moments of reprieve you are given is
only so that he can buff himself
well-timed roles are critical it's a
brilliantly paced fight and the tragedy
of having to take down a corrupted
legendary hero makes our Tauruses story
one of the most memorable in series what
makes Dark Souls 3 is final boss so
great is how it's a love letter to the
series as a whole it's hard to just not
get giddy about the whole thing
the first phase has the soul of sender
swapping out different playstyles meant
to represent all the players throughout
the series one second they're an
aggressive fast hitter the next third
projectile wielding magic user he can
even do that special role that came from
the dark woodgrain ring in Dark Souls 1
if that's not a commitment a fanservice
I don't know what is that's not even
mentioning the second phase where the
soul of cinder takes on the persona of
Gwen and you are treated to what is a
superior version of the Dark Souls 1
final boss a rewarding callback for
longtime fans and an impressive fight in
its own right the soul of cinder is the
perfect send-off to the series
in a series filled with many dual bosses
orenstein and SMO is without a doubt the
best there's a yin and yang to the two
of them with their abilities
complimenting each other perfectly your
control any management over the fight is
key and it can feel overwhelming and
impossible if you let it but in reality
it's a fair challenge the second phase
changes depending on who you kill first
a unique concept that never is really
replicated later on in the series each
souped-up version provides his own
challenge and the different wards you
get provided small but cool branching
choice for the players it's orange teams
Mo's legacy for players though that
really puts them so high on this list
they are the crucible for new souls
players in Dark Souls 1 it's the
make-or-break moment where players
conquer or give up
picture this you're fighting in abyss
watcher when suddenly a second one rises
from the dead and attacks you okay we've
seen this before and then a third rises
but this time it starts attacking the
other two and suddenly you have an ally
this bait-and-switch of what you expect
from a gank fight is what makes the
abyss watcher such a brilliant fight the
second phase is also a lovely call back
to Artorias as well as the whole lore
itself the abyss Watchers carried on our
traces work raising cities to the ground
to stop the abyss now consumed by the
abyss themselves and unable to die they
are locked in an endless battle with
each other in many ways the abyss
watchers are a combination of the series
different ba styles forms to make one
fight there's such a joy and real to the
whole thing that once conquered you want
to go back and do it again
a corpse should be left whether though
lady Maria is a perfect boss her story
and fight bleed naturally with each
other and the challenge she presents is
frenetic difficult and just so much fun
as a hunter fight Maria's abilities
mirror your own creating a dance between
the two of you as you trade blows with
each other each of her phases ramps up
the pace and actually feeds into her
story for she's a broken person so
determined to prevent you from finding
the secret she wishes to protect that
she will use the very art of blood
weapons that she hates
Maria is unraveling the pace increases
the music swells the clock shines
Maria's fight is flawless and the very
best the series has to offer did we miss
any of your favorites unsatisfied with
the pics please we would love to hear
from you let us know in the comments
below and remember be nice we're all
friends here if you want to see more
videos like this hit the subscribe
button and stay tuned to game spot
you